Good evening, everybody.
And welcome to the first of the
workshop series for the $15K
Creative Arts Competition.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe.
And I am joined here with
my colleague, Theo Fields.
Say hello, Theo.
Hello.
We're here this
evening, and we're
going to be discussing value
propositions with Dr. Michael
Camp from the Ohio
State University.
I'm going to turn
it over to Dr. Camp.
Do a quick introduction,
and then we're off.
Great.
Well, thank you, Shannon.
Thank you, Theo.
It's good to be with you.
I appreciate that all the
way from Columbus, Ohio.
As I was saying earlier,
it's just a little
over 50 degrees today, but
it was very cold yesterday.
So, glad to be inside,
glad to be on Zoom.
Very excited to be able to
share with you, tonight.
Let me go ahead
and share a screen.
And we'll get the
presentation started.
OK, yeah, just in the way
of a brief introduction,
I'll leave a lot of
what's on the slide,
in case you're going
to be delivering
the slides intact at
a later point in time.
For the most part, just
wanted to summarize,
I'm currently at the
Ohio State University
and have been there since 2004.
However, I actually finished
my doctorate work there back
in the '90s.
And so I've been associated
with the Ohio State
University for quite some time.
I've taught at the Fisher
College of Business.
I'm now in the College
of engineering.
I've actually run almost all of
the various interdisciplinary
hybrid experiential educational
programs in innovation
and entrepreneurship.
Some of them are
now on their own.
And I'm not involved
with them any longer,
the Langdale TEC Academy
and a variety of others.
I'm currently mostly responsible
for the I-Corps@Ohio program,
which trains research
scientists and graduate students
in the advanced principles of
technology entrepreneurship.
And I'm working on some
undergraduate programming
within the Center for Design
and Manufacturing Excellence
on innovation and technology.
Entrepreneurship,
there's not a big focus.
If you can believe that,
with such a big school,
there's not a big focus
from the undergraduates
in the engineering program
on entrepreneurship.
So we thought we'd better course
correct there pretty quickly.
So anyway, there's more detail
there on the slide for you.
You know, it was
interesting when
I got asked to share with you
this evening, I was a bit--
I guess, the best
word is perplexed.
Because of the notion
of what I understand
art entrepreneurship
to be and what
the general theme of
entrepreneurship is.
And I thought what
might be a great way
to start so that we make sure
we're all on the same page is
just to start with
what I found to be
a pretty interesting
definition of entrepreneurship.
The field of
entrepreneurship, it's
been around since
the '70s for the most
part as an academic discipline.
And to a large extent,
the definitions
that we use in
terms of researching
it and understanding
what we mean by the word
entrepreneurship or
entrepreneurial behavior
really has never taken root.
There's a lot of disagreement
among the scholars.
And there's a lot
of effort to make
the word relate to
whatever makes its best
usefulness for the academic
programs that you're pursuing.
I found this
particular definition.
It's very consistent
with mine, though it's
got one small variation.
But this was from James Hart.
And I liked it because he's
from the School of Art at SMU.
He says that entrepreneurship,
the creation of opportunity
and value with intent to
profit in a variety of ways
through the assumption
of risk and effort.
And one of the few examples
that, like me, actually focuses
on the assumption of risk.
And I was asked to speak
on value proposition.
This is a really tough
topic to speak on.
And I'll share as we go through
here in just a few minutes
why it is very challenging.
But for the most part,
it's because it's
at the center of what
entrepreneurship means,
the notion of both creating
and capturing value
and also at the same time
executing the discipline
and the mechanics of actually
running a business in order
to capture that value.
These are the
critical components
that are very challenging
to actually identify.
They're very
challenging to evaluate.
And they're very
challenging to execute.
And so for me, this is
the bread and butter
of all entrepreneurship,
regardless of art
entrepreneurship or otherwise.
And I thought to myself, if
you'll give me the permission,
I'm going to just
venture off here
for just a second to talk
about what I think of when I
think of arts entrepreneurship.
If you take the definition
we just identified,
there's really three
ways I can slice it.
And I look at the
entrepreneurial effort
as the enterprise
in the arts industry
as one component
that is established
in the means by
which we buy and sell
art or artistic expression.
And I would think of
examples like Shutterfly.
I know that the
competition you're in now
is a strong focus on the
role that technology plays
in advancing both the creation
and distribution and trade
of art itself.
I think this is one
particular context that
makes an interesting
or would provide
an interesting
perspective in terms
of what we're thinking about.
I'm sure several of
your teams are actually
focusing on arts
entrepreneurship
in this regard, the means of
buying and selling and using
technology to exploit that.
However, there's also the notion
of enterprise for the arts.
And I thought it was a nice
example of Michelangelo
with the Sistine Chapel.
You probably know well, he
was actually paid to do that
and in fact, had to be
bribed significantly in order
to leave a job he
already had that he
was being paid for in
order to take on the job
and was paid what
was, at the time,
pretty handsomely what
took four years to create.
So we'll talk a
little bit in a moment
about the notion
of value creation
and how time, investment, cost,
opportunity all come into play
and have to be considered
in terms of our venture
opportunities as to whether the
value we're actually creating,
the value proposition,
which we're
developing within
our enterprises
are really worth the
opportunity or worth the effort.
And thirdly, the notion
of enterprise as art.
This is using our
creative expression
to create sustainable and
long lasting solutions.
For me, this is the essence of
what I do in entrepreneurship.
I never would have called it
arts entrepreneurship or don't
call it arts entrepreneurship.
But for me, the art is actually
in the design and creation
of the underlying
business model enterprise
and how you can solve unique
and challenging problems
in the world through
the power of enterprise.
And I believe just like
a canvas of an artist,
my business model is a canvas
by which I can create and make
lasting impact and significant
meaning through the work
that I do.
And so for me, I've
had opportunities
to develop thousands
of artistic expression
says enterprise as art itself.
And I thought this was just
a nice way to characterize,
depending on where the
teams are coming from.
I wouldn't have any idea.
I haven't read any of your
original idea pitches.
And I probably won't
be there at the end
to see those pitches at the
end of the final program.
So just wanted to
share that with you
as a way of contextualizing
what we're talking about.
For me, I also am
fairly simplistic.
I like to break down the
concepts of something
like value proposition
so once again,
to make sure we're
all on the same page.
So while we have
multiple contexts
in which to think about
how we create value
through our enterprising
initiatives,
what is it that we're
really creating when we
talk about a value proposition?
And simply put,
the notion of value
is the importance worth
or usefulness of whatever
the target focus is,
whatever the thing
is we're talking about.
The proposition is the
notion of a statement
that expresses that concept
and can be true or false.
And when I mentioned
earlier the notion of risk,
therein lies the
essence of risk in terms
of how we create value.
In this instance, our value
propositions, the proposals,
if you will, the
propositions we're
making regarding how our
new enterprises are going
to create value are
actually statements
that express the
concept at its essence
but also can be true or false.
And that's the
critical distinction.
What we want to talk about
this evening is regardless
of context in
terms of how you're
using your creative
expression to drive value
through your
enterprising initiatives,
the key here is that
the basis on which you
determine what the
value proposition is
is either true or false.
And essentially, that's
what it comes down to.
The fundamentals of
value proposition--
though, I wish we had time.
I literally teach an entire
month of a 2 and 1/2 month
course on just this concept.
Typically, we're working with
high technology businesses.
However, much of that technology
embeds the creative expression
in the research
scientists who have
developed those inventions.
And so there's a strong
creative expression
that's actually undergirding all
of the initiatives that we do.
And in understanding the
value of the proposition,
you have to ask yourself
these key considerations
or the key
fundamental questions.
In other words, the
risk is, if you go back
to the definition earlier,
the notion of the effort,
the risk associated.
This question is is it feasible?
It's one thing to have
invented something in a lab
or to be tinkering
with something at home
and identify a unique way
to manipulate technology
to create different outcomes.
The question, however,
in value proposition
is can we really create
sustainable value?
What is the value
creative potential
of what we've developed
or what we've discovered?
Is it feasible?
And that's determined by based
on the notion of time and cost
associated with its achievement.
Again, we can't simply stop with
that first initial discovery.
We have to understand that if
value is going to be created,
it's going to be
solving problems.
And if so, it's going
to be introduced
into the marketplace.
And so the notion of the risk
or the time and cost associated
with making it feasible has
to be taken into consideration
when we're thinking
of value propositions.
It's also the notion
of value, itself.
Go figure.
But in this case, the
question is is it different?
In other words, does it create
new value, net new value?
And that value was
created by the degree
to which the solution
addresses the core parameters
of the problem.
And you may say
resolves the problem
or resolves the core components
of the problem, perhaps not
all the components.
You can imagine a number of
solutions, artistic or not,
that solve some portion
of a particular problem
but only address that
particular piece and that needs
other solutions in order to
derive the total resolution.
And the third and final
is is it necessary?
In other words, is
it necessary means
is it likely to be adopted
or utilized and deployed?
And will there be an
opportunity for this notion
of what we call the trade, the
transaction activity, where
we capture the
value that we embed
or create within our products
and services solutions?
And that is represented in
the buy and sell transaction
activity that happens around
those new products and services
that we introduced.
So think of your idea.
Think of the
creative idea you're
considering now as part
of this competition.
Is it feasible?
How is it different,
if it's different?
And why is it necessary?
And you'll find that these
are critical questions
that if you can answer, not
only increase your confidence
in the enterprising initiative
you're trying to undergird
with the art
expression, you'll also
find that it's the
essential element
to build your confidence
to move forward.
And those are the
key considerations in
whether or not you ever do
start this venture you're
playing with at this time.
This is an interesting
quote in the process
of trying to find
this illustration
to drive home the point
about the different context.
I came across the quote
from Michelangelo.
And I thought it was intriguing.
"If you knew how much
work went into it,
you would not call it genius."
Now, if any of you are
art majors or art students
or professionals, you probably
have come across this.
It might not mean much to you.
But in the context of value
proposition and value creation,
this is a very interesting
quote to decipher.
Again, we won't spend
much time with it.
But think about what
that means with respect
to the notion of
the overall art that
was created, the effort that
had to go in to create this art.
And yes, by the way, as
I mentioned, he was paid
and was paid well
according to the times.
But what about the trade,
the buy-sell concept?
Was it worth it?
Do you believe there
was value captured?
Now we look at this
piece of art today,
and we see the intrinsic value.
I mean, it moves
your soul or should
or perhaps, or that
was the intent.
But does it ultimately
have extrinsic value?
And would it have been
perceived as such at the time?
When I start to translate
some of these concepts
into the type of
ventures that I start
or help to start
on a regular basis,
whether it be through my
students or the research
scientist that we're
training or some
of the consulting activities,
just like artists use a canvas,
we use what we call the
Business Model Canvas.
And this is a very
simple rendering
of what the Business
Model Canvas is.
And like most of these
types of illustrations,
they really are in
and of themselves
of any particular
insight or value.
The importance of this
Canvas is it's simply
a way of organizing
your information.
Ultimately, in order to
articulate a clear, compelling
value proposition,
you have to be
able to show how it embeds
within an overarching business
model.
It's not enough to just simply
describe the value proposition.
In fact, it's not
possible in and of itself.
If you see how the
value proposition is
positioned within this canvas,
it's directly in the center.
And immediately to the right
is the customer segments
and all the ways in which
the value proposition serves
the needs of those
customer segments, again,
depending on the
nature of that segment
and the nature of the
product service offering.
There's a variety of ways in
which value proposition serves
it.
But if you look
immediately to the left,
these are all the ways in which
we create the value proposition
that solves and serves the
needs of the customer segments.
Those value creating
competencies
around key activities, key
resources, and key partnerships
are the critical backbone of
the notion of value proposition.
So it's not enough to have a
compelling value proposition.
It's only compelling
to the extent
we believe you can deliver.
And the only way
we can believe you
can deliver if you
clearly understand
what the key activities
are that you're
going to need to master in
order to deliver that value
proposition and what
key resources you're
going to have to have in
order to sustain that,
and where you don't have
those resources, what
key partnerships are
you going to have
to build into your
overarching model
in order to deliver
that path ultimately
to drive solutions to your
customers that are better
than alternative competitive
solutions on the market now.
So this is really an
organizing framework.
But for me, from an
artistic standpoint,
I envision it as a very
powerful and compelling canvas
by which we can--
or lump of clay by which we can
sculpt a compelling business
model.
And it might sound
like a play on words,
but I actually do
consider myself
to be fairly arts-oriented.
I come from a
family of that sort.
And I'm actually,
personality-wise,
much of a designer,
builder type.
And I'm constantly, whether I'm
building educational programs
or building startup
opportunities or new ventures,
there's always a design
and creative articulation
that is embedded in
all of that work.
What we're driving for here
in a clear, compelling sense
is this notion of fit.
We want to understand clearly
how our solution fits the needs
or solves the problems
in a compelling way
with the customer segments.
And I'm going to come
back to this at least one
other time, if not
more, and we'll
explain there's actually
more to that story.
But we have to develop
our thoughts here
for just a moment.
When you get this deck,
this will be a slide
that you can use as
a reference slide.
I'm not going to
pour over this slide.
This was actually
from an article
I used in the MBA class.
I thought it was nicely
summarized as a way
to consider what a
value proposition is,
what it consists of, and
what challenges it addresses
for the customer, what
is required in order
for it to be compelling, and
what are some of the challenges
and risks associated with it.
And then you see
how that plays out
across the different columns.
What I'd like you to--
what I would like to
point out and what
I hope you'll discern when
you spend a little bit of time
with this is the notion of
value propositions, direct link
and time consideration of
the customer and the customer
segment.
And it's not enough to simply
know who your customer is.
And while this is a nice
additional-- a nice summary
resource to use, it falls
short in what I believe
to be a critical component.
But once you know that component
and you read this chart
through that lens, you'll
have a deep and comprehensive
perspective of what these terms
mean and how relevant they are.
And we're going to talk about
that perspective in a moment.
Before we jump to that,
are there any questions
at all about what we
mean by value proposition
and what we mean by the
context of value proposition
creation and arts and
arts entrepreneurship?
If people have questions,
they can either
unmute to ask Dr.
Camp, or I will happily
receive those through the chat.
OK.
Looks like everything is
smooth sailing so far.
So I will just let you continue.
Very good.
I think it would be fun to just
talk about a good illustration.
I'm sorry, I don't have a
better one at the moment
to match up with
the arts competition
that you're going to.
As I've said
already though, I do
believe that there's
enormous creative expression,
enormous use of technology
in a lot of product markets
that I spend time.
My work for has crossed over 36
different technology verticals
from the medical to the
software to materials
and ag-related bioproducts.
And so I don't have a problem
transitioning or perhaps
the better word is
translating these concepts
from one segment to the next.
And yet I see this as an
enormous expression of--
or an illustration
that expresses
the enormous potential in
the world of value creation.
If you'll look at the
notion of the Keurig Kold--
I don't know if anybody's
familiar with Keurig Kold.
And I wish I could see you,
so you could raise your hand.
But it's not that important.
The critical consideration
is you're probably all
familiar with the Keurig Hot.
Well, before there was a Keurig
Hot, there was just Keurig.
And Keurig Hot came to
be because of the Keurig
Kold and the notion of
having to differentiate
how you get a hot beverage
versus you get a cold beverage.
And this was a partnership
that was launched with Keurig
in partnership with Coca-Cola to
develop the same type of K-Cup
type technology
that would deliver
a cold carbonated beverage
as opposed to a hot beverage.
And I just wondered if anybody
was familiar with that.
Very, very interesting, very,
very exciting technology.
Actually, a beautiful design.
Again, in my opinion,
extremely artistic,
extremely well-laid-out.
There over 150
issued patents inside
of the Keurig Kold that was
developed along the way.
However, so the
bottom line, there's
really fundamentally
nothing wrong
with this concept in
its technical sense.
Fundamentally, it can
perform if we knew
that it was feasible to work.
This is actually an
illustration taken actually
directly from one of those
patents, the patent around
how to put the carbon dioxide
directly into the solution
in order to make the
carbonated beverage.
All of those little
individual pieces
are actually identified
in the patent.
So a very interesting
piece of technology
but one of the most disastrous
new product innovations
of all time.
I mean, ranks up
there as a classic.
Even if you haven't
heard of Keurig Kold,
if you understand the
facts behind this case,
you know exactly how
disastrous this was.
It was pulled off the
market in less than 9 months
about just shy of six years.
And $1 billion went into
the research and development
of the product.
It was taken off the
market less than one
year after the company
had already been acquired.
So even in the acquisition
of the company, the process
with due diligence, this product
would have been evaluated.
And so even the
acquirers would have not
known that this was going to be
as disastrous at the time they
acquired it.
But more importantly,
135 employees
in the state of
Vermont lost their job.
And that's pretty unfortunate.
And I would ask,
so what went wrong?
But we could probably identify,
just brainstorming, a half
a dozen different concepts.
I could tell you that the cost
of each individual 8 ounce
glass of carbonated
beverage was about $1.32.
The machine was about twice
as big as a Keurig Hot,
so it literally takes up a
third of your kitchen counter.
It's also extremely
heavy, and there
are very few K-Cups that were
actually available at the time.
There were several
Coca-Cola products,
but that was about
it and a few other.
But that was about it.
But the bottom line
is there really
was no problem-solution fit.
In other words, if you would've
asked any of these engineers,
you can bet they had a very
strong value proposition.
They were convinced.
Even Keurig and Coca-Cola, two
of the top consumer beverage
brands in the world who have
millions of customers and could
go on to any number of those
customers to get a clear,
compelling sense of whether
or not this product solved any
problem or not, and they didn't.
And if they did, they were
biased in their approach.
Because it didn't show any
evidence that no one would
want to buy.
Oh, and by the way, the
machine was about $650
when it first came
out, so about twice
as expensive as the Keurig
Hot when it first came out
and even more so by the
time it was widely adopted.
So let's not get
into any confusion
that any one of these elements
is what was the downfall.
The reality is
they were building
a product nobody wanted.
And this is a critical
consideration.
And I know you're only at
the idea stage of your arts
entrepreneurship competition.
But I will tell you that
it's at that stage where
all startups begin.
And the need for or
intention to go beyond that
must be driven by your clear
understanding of the problem
and solution fit.
You remember, the value
proposition, again,
is this importance or worth,
their usefulness of something.
Let's take the Keurig Kold.
Its importance was dependent
on some key considerations.
And those statements
of importance
were either true or false.
And the best time to
determine the validity
of those statements
is now, today.
During the idea stage is a time
in which you not only create
the value proposition, you
validate and confirm the value
proposition along the way.
We have this precept
in all of our teaching
that's a nice quote.
I use quotes for
all of my precepts.
But and it's from
Mark Twain that it
ain't what you don't know
that gets you into trouble.
It's what you know for
sure that just ain't so.
So the reality of testing
the value proposition
of your business is not
that this value proposition
lives in some obscure
reality that somehow we've
been enlightened in terms
of the needs of our market
and we know exactly
what the customer wants.
The reality is that's all
driven by the assumptions we're
making, which are
driven by our own biases
and our own ignorance and
the own lack of understanding
of what really happens.
I can point you
to dozens of teams
that were convinced
that they were going
to solve a particular
problem only
to get testing into the market
and find out the problem didn't
really exist, or the solution
was way over complicated
for the notion of the problem.
So it's important that
we understand and think
about those carefully.
Let's look at this situation
that has a near zero
probability of being correct.
This is a new venture idea
that was based on the following
assumptions.
You would probably
recognize it right away.
First assumption is
that there are too
few affordable hotels in the
city for short term stays.
People are probably willing
to pay for alternative options
if the hotels are not available.
People are probably
willing to compromise
on some of those original
amenities in order just
to save money.
There's probably
enough people that
would be willing to do this
that I could make a profit.
Other people might
even be willing to rent
one or more bedrooms
in their apartments.
And there are
probably enough people
willing to sub-rent
their apartments
that we might be able to
establish a sustainable
service.
Well, it's not hard
to guess Airbnb.
And you know that that's
a pretty wild success.
However, if you understand how
Airbnb actually was created,
you would realize that each
one of these individual steps
were tested,
actually live tested
with customers in the
market before they ever
wrote a business
plan, before they ever
took out a bank loan,
before they ever
decided to find partners.
They literally just
talked to their friends
and made their rooms
available in their extra rooms
in their apartments, put a
small website together, and then
added more rooms.
And by the time
they ever wrote what
might be considered
a business plan,
they were already
multi-million dollar business
and already had actually
achieved other successes
as well.
So but don't fret
about the Keurig Kold.
Rest assured, Keurig has
figured out all of its problems
and what went wrong.
And they've now introduced
Drinkworks Home Bar.
So although the Keurig Kold
was a colossal failure,
Keurig is 100% convinced
that Drinkworks Home Bar,
a single-serve, pod-based
premium cocktail spritzer
machine, is exactly
what we all want.
And this is going to go
rolling off the shelves
just any time soon.
These are, yes,
K-Cups that create
carbonated alcoholic
mixed beverages.
And that's it, they
figured it out.
Yeah, sure, we'll see.
However, let's bring all of this
back a little closer to home
and looking at what
we're dealing with.
Another near zero
probability of being
correct set of assumptions
are exactly where
you are right now.
And in this instance,
with respect
to how your new venture will
create value or capture value,
you're making some
core assumptions.
At least all the teams
that I've coached up
through this point of
25 years of doing this
typically make these
assumptions going in,
it's why they decided
to enter the competition
in the first place.
There's a level of
confidence in the assumptions
you're making about
your new venture idea.
You are assuming that the
customer you're focused on
has the problem
you're focused on
and knows that they
have a problem.
Let's hope that they've
tried alternative solutions,
and nothing's worked
up to this point.
They can't articulate
what they need.
That's a really big assumption.
And they know how valuable
an alternative solution would
be if it solved that problem.
And you're probably
already making
assumptions regarding
how much they
might be willing to pay
for such a solution.
At the same time, which is
the second side, the risk
side associated--
or actually on the
buy-sell side associated
with value proposition,
we're assuming
that the solution we
can make addresses
those pain points and
performs better than anything
already in the market.
And it doesn't require
any significant change
in the current workflow
and doesn't increase
the cost of adopting our
product over alternatives
and we can sell it for x in
order to sustain the operations
and make a profit
for our new venture.
Some of you could give
your final pitch right now.
Some of you, based
on these assumptions,
could today write a business
plan and pitch for funding.
It happens all the time.
But remember that the key to
a strong value proposition--
the key is the evidence
to determine if it's true.
The evidence that it's true
is what establishes your value
proposition.
And remember that
the value proposition
is the essential ingredient
to your entire business model.
Without a compelling
value proposition,
that you can prove
is true, you really
have left in question the
entire business concept.
Even though you may have a
lot of other aspects completed
until this is fully
articulated, there's really not
much else to be believed.
There's very little confidence.
We have a saying in the I-Corps
training program in Ohio.
As I said, as a graduate
student and research scientist
led entrepreneurship
initiative training initiative
that we don't care
what you think.
We're not really even
interested in what you believe.
The only thing that matters
is what you can prove.
And that's where value
proposition comes in.
So we're moving into the last
segment of our few minutes
together.
Are there any questions about
any of those illustrations
and the importance of
understanding our customer
segments and why that level
of understanding and depth
of clarity is necessary
in order to generate
a good compelling
value proposition?
So far everything seems
pretty clear to me.
And I am just desperate to
see how that cocktail Keurig
thing works out.
[LAUGHS] Well, I stopped
short of telling you
that I had bought one
of those Keutig Kolds.
However, I bought it
after I knew that it was
being pulled off the market.
Because I wanted to use
it as a good example.
If we were in
class this evening,
I would have it
sitting behind me,
and you'd get a chance
to at least try that.
But I intend to get
one of these too,
particularly, if it
goes off the market.
But either way, I intend
to get one of these too.
Excellent, I will look
forward to a full report.
Very good, very good.
Well, we're moving now into
a bit granular approach
to actually
understanding how do we
evaluate the customer and the
customer profile in what we're
doing.
And again, I have an
entire 12 week semester
with finals and
presentations and everything
around just this concept alone.
And this is at the center
of the I-Corps program.
So we're going to
get a few minutes.
And I apologize we
can't go deeper.
I'm happy to answer any
questions in the future
or our future iterations.
Or if you want to email me,
I'll make my email available.
So happy to be
helpful, but we're
going to really cover
it superficially.
So please ask questions if I
either go too quickly or too
superficially.
The notion of the
Business Model Canvas,
as we showed a little bit ago.
And I mentioned to
you that the key here
is clarifying this value
proposition and its link or fit
with the customer profile
and the pains and problems
the customer is having in
achieving the jobs they
are intended to achieve.
Well, there's the
same group that
developed that canvas map,
that Business Model Canvas,
developed this Value
Proposition Canvas.
And if you have
familiarity with it,
I'm not going to go into
a deep dive in terms
of the dynamics of
how the mapping works.
But I'm going to talk
a little bit about each
of the individual pieces.
I didn't want to
bore someone who
maybe uses this in
a number of classes
or you're using it
now in the program.
Or I didn't want to
be too loose with any
of these individual pieces.
Because you maybe
already covered it.
But all this is is
just a break-out
of those two segments.
But we break them out, because
it takes my teams, anyway,
four out of eight weeks that
when we run the eight week
I-Corp program, it's at least
four weeks before the teams can
articulate to my satisfaction.
And I'll explain what I mean by
that before they can articulate
clearly how the value
proposition they create
through the products or services
they offer drive directly value
created into the
customer for the jobs
he or she's trying to perform.
And I literally get them down
to that level of clarity.
And when I say
customers here, I'm
not talking about,
in this case, just
like the automotive market
or the arts industry
or the theater program.
I'm literally talking about
who, what job by job title
would be the user,
payer, influencer
of the purchase of my product
or service as I'm addressing.
If you can't articulate that,
you leave a big question
in my mind as to
whether you really
know whether you
create any value or not
or solve any legitimate
problem or not.
So these are not
abstract concepts.
These are literally down
to hand-to-hand combat.
We're literally talking face
to face, in this case, Zoom
to Zoom, if you will.
We're talking directly
with our customers.
Let's talk for a moment about
the notion of the customer
profile.
This is where you want to
start your customer discovery
activity as trying to identify
do I have a compelling value
proposition or not.
Is it feasible, is it
different, and is it valuable?
Does it matter?
Why should it exist?
These are critical
considerations.
The first thing you
have to understand
is you have to explain
who do I assume
is going to use my product.
And then who do I assume,
if my user doesn't
buy, who's going to buy my
products so my customer can
use it?
And then if my buyer
doesn't actually use it
or can't influence
the decision, who
influences the decision
so that my buyer can buy
or so that my
customer can use it.
And sometimes our concepts
are business to consumer.
They're websites, and these
are not complicated matters.
Other times they're
medical devices.
And there's 14 levels
of decision maker
you have to go through in
order to get them approved.
So I'm not sure where
anybody is at any time.
But I can tell you for sure,
if you can't articulate it
back to me in a simple way and
an effective and compelling
way, I'm not going to
believe you know it either.
And that's the key what
we're talking about today.
So in this sense is
these are the set
of customer characteristics
that in the most important word
is there that you can
validate with actual customers
in the market.
The first thing you
need to understand
are the customer jobs.
And that literally is
just asking the customer
that I think has
the problem that
would use my product, what
is his or her job, what
is it they do?
They're a design engineer at
an automotive manufacturing
facility.
OK, what do they do?
OK, they design parts,
They design systems.
They write software.
They meet schedules.
But then I ask the
pains and gains.
What I want to know there
is, well, what challenges,
what are the difficulties they
have at getting that job done?
All their software
is too archaic.
They have too many
different softwares that
don't link with each other.
It takes too long.
It's too much done by committee.
There's no other
design graphic software
that would make
it more effective,
whatever it might be.
And then the other is the gains.
What are the things
they would like
to achieve but
can't because they
lack the adequate opportunity or
resource, the adequate product
or solution that
you might provide.
Maybe they would like to be
able to save time in the designs
or share the designs with more
of the different designers
across their company
in order to get
things facilitated more
efficiently or more
effectively.
So a host of those things.
Maybe not the best
example, but you
need to understand your customer
at a detailed level in terms
of what job are they trying
to create and what challenges
and gains are they trying
to achieve with that job.
And on the value
proposition side,
the notion here is that do we
have a set of characteristics
that actually allow the
customer to achieve those gains
or resolve those pains
associated with their jobs.
And remember
ultimately, though, we
have to be able
to do this better
than the current
alternative products.
If these are real problems the
customer is trying to solve,
he or she would have
already been looking
for alternative solutions.
In fact, they may have already
been testing and paying
for solutions that
they're not happy with
and maybe even adopting them
and using because there's
nothing else available.
Your best customer,
the best person
to understand what
they need, is someone
that's already looking
for solutions, better yet,
has already paid for
alternative solutions
that they're not happy with.
Now you're not solving
the original problem,
you're solving the
problem that they're
having with the alternative
solutions that don't work well.
All of a sudden now you've
shifted the priority
and a higher level of
interest in your product
if it can resolve
those types of issues.
So ultimately, we're bringing
all of that together.
So when we've captured
that information,
we can put it on a
graphic, something
like this that says, well, how
are the pain relievers or pain
elevators associated
with our products
and services actually relieve
the pains of our customers
in order to allow them
to do their job better.
Or better yet, how do the
benefits of our solutions
actually drive new
and improved scenarios
that the customer can either
do more or do more with less.
And so it requires two things, a
clear understanding of the jobs
and the pains and
gains of the customer
and then an evaluation of
how your product actually
matches or solves or fits--
the word fit-- in order to
solve those pains and gains.
And that's what we mean by the
notion of problem-solution fit.
And this is why
Keurig didn't work,
or the Keurig Kold anyway,
why it didn't work.
I couldn't pinpoint exactly.
But I could tell you
just my own experience,
I used to curate
for years, and I
could have told you
immediately that the Kold made
no sense to me, and I would
not be interested in it.
So as we wrap up
here, after many weeks
of this particular
program, you're
going to be in for weeks
and weeks in these training
workshops and the
research on your efforts
and all the mentoring that
you're going to be getting.
I found it interesting
if nothing's
changed in the priorities or the
parameters of the competition,
you're going to get five
minutes to tell your story.
Multiple weeks of training
research and mentoring,
and you're going to get five
minutes to tell your story.
Now, the last thing
you want to do
is try to fit all your
information into that five
minutes.
So I ask you, what
is the storyline?
What is the compelling
and convincing storyline
that you have to tell in order
to achieve a victory in a five
minute presentation?
Now, you might be
thinking I'm going to say
it's the value proposition.
And I would tell
you it's not enough.
It is the value proposition
in terms of its key role,
but stay with me
for one more second.
We have to understand
the customer.
You only needed an idea to get
into the competition program.
But to win, you're going
to have to leave your idea,
leave it on the
desktop, and get out
of the building, as
commonly referred to,
virtually if necessary, and
talk directly to your customers.
Your business model, who is
your customer-- first of all,
while you're evolving
business model,
it is by its nature, a
value creation engine.
Therefore, everyone your
business touches, customers,
suppliers, end users,
payers, purchasers, whatever,
however it's delineated
across from start
to finish on the decision
to buy your product instead
of one of your competitors,
those are your customers.
And if you need a
partner in order
to deliver a unique feature
inside of a software,
they are part of your customer.
In other words, anyone
who derives value
from participating with you
and your business proposition
is a customer.
Remember, you're
doing this in order
to create and capture value.
There's many reasons
why some to sustain
your enterprise but
others to change the world
and make a meaningful impact
and sustain that change so it
can impact people for years
to come, whatever it might be.
As a value creation engine,
think of your enterprises
in that way.
Anybody who drives
or contributes
becomes a customer in your
customer discovery process.
And here are the keys.
You've got to acknowledge
the critical assumptions that
undergird why you
think this is going
to be a successful business.
And that means come clean, get
in a room with your team, Zoom
room if it has to
be, get in a room
and come clean on everything
you're assuming to be true.
In other words, ask yourself
what has to be true for this
to be real?
And then you're going to
document those, and then
go out and empirically
test those directly
with your potential customers.
You need to be able to
articulate with evidence
what problems they
are trying to solve,
not what problem
you think they have
but what problems are
they trying to solve.
What alternative
solutions have they tried?
And what value does
your technology
create if it solves
the problem better?
Your focus must be
on understanding
their past and current
behaviors, not opinions.
It doesn't matter if I said if
I had a product of this sort,
would you buy one?
And they said, oh, sure.
It's a useless data.
It's not even meaningful.
Ask them what was
the last product they
bought to try to solve this.
How did that work out?
Were they happy
with the decision?
What didn't work out?
What are they looking for now?
And what would they pay for
a solution that did that is--
or what did they pay for the
solution that didn't work out?
That is the notion of what they
perceive to be valuable or not.
That's data you can trust.
Their past behavior is the
key to proving the value
in your proposed
product or service.
And then, again, wrapping
up, as we've said,
the value proposition,
your ability
to prove that value proposition,
is the essential element
of how your whole business
model holds together.
And remember, five minutes,
just five minutes you've got
to get this across.
In other words, you've got
to contract your space.
You've got to bring
the message in.
You've got to be very simple.
But in that simple message,
it's got to be clear
and it's got to be compelling
in order for you to win.
OK, spoiler alert, I know
who the winner is this year.
I'm sorry, Shannon
and Theo, I hate
to let the cat out of the bag.
But the winner this
year is the team
that can prove the problem's
real, the market's large,
the team can deliver,
and the solution
ensures a strong and competitive
fit with customer needs.
In other words, can prove.
You'll hear a lot
of presentations
at the end of this program where
the team's still speculating,
they think, they believe,
they're confident.
The team that can prove
with evidence directly
from customers that their
value proposition is real
is going to heads and
shoulders above the others.
And it's very clear in a
five minute presentation
which ones are able
to achieve that.
Well, I'm open.
I think that was it.
Yep.
All right.
Let the games begin.
Oh, fabulous.
Do you mind if I pop this
back into gallery view,
so we're sort of able
to converse a bit?
Absolutely.
All right.
I hope there's a lot
of open conversation.
All right.
So does anybody have any
initial questions, thoughts?
It would also be great to
see some people on camera.
I am familiar with some
of you but not all of you.
So it would be nice to sort
of see who is in the room
and see what kind
of conversation
we can get going in
the next few minutes.
Don't be shy.
People are thinking, Shannon,
I have to ask, I hate to admit,
I don't know what
that is behind you.
What is your graphic?
Ooh, OK, this is King's
College Chapel in Cambridge
over in the UK, probably
my favorite place
that I've ever sung.
Because the acoustics
on those fan
vault ceilings are unparalleled.
I've never sung anywhere
in the states, maybe
the cathedral of
St. John the Divine,
because it's just so huge.
But any of the places where
I've done nice singing,
this takes the cake.
That is awesome.
All right.
Well, for the
benefit of people who
are watching this
asynchronously,
I think one question in order
to avoid it being a Keurig
and kind of continuing
to kind of bark up a tree
that maybe doesn't have
value, how should teams
think about potentially changing
their big why or their value
problem?
What's the best
strategies for doing that,
and how can you do that
effectively while still
kind of preserving
your initial mission?
Yeah, that's a
really good question.
Just to be as simple
about it, I didn't
discuss the notion of a term
we refer to lean startup.
Again, it might be a common
term your teams or students have
used.
But the notion of this
customer discovery activity
is because we're
trying to go fast.
In other words, we want
to get to the nose.
We know there's a lot
of the assumptions we're
making that aren't
real or aren't true.
And in the process of doing
it effectively and doing it
deliberately, we're
going to uncover.
Where those gaps are.
So trust me, all of your
ideas are going to pivot.
They're all going to modify
either slightly or greatly.
But the how we do
that is actually
derived from the
discovery process itself.
I don't want you
to think that this
is I'm going to go talk
to a bunch of customers
and realize my business
is dead in the water.
Nobody needs what I have.
What I'm going to do now?
It's actually in the
discovery process
by really being
honest with yourself
not trying to simply validate
that you have the greatest
solution in the world but really
understanding their problems
and understanding how they look
for alternative solutions now
and what they're willing
to pay for those solutions
where the next idea will emerge.
I tell my teams all the time,
the last thing you want to do
is go in with I've got
a one-step solution,
if you don't want
it, you must not
be smart enough to know you
need it, or I'm out of business,
that neither of those are true.
You're going to learn
through the discovery process
whether your initial
assumptions are right.
But that data is also
going to tell you where
your appropriate pivots are.
I've had teams go all the way
to completely different market
segments.
I could share the
stories if we had time.
But literally from one
medical segment to a drone.
They were now doing
battery-powered systems
for drones all the way
from heart implants,
literally in a five week period.
And how do they do that?
Were they jumping
around making--
no, they started with
a core assumption
they believed in, tested
it, invalidated it,
and what they learned from that
validation or invalidation told
them where to go next.
So I hope that's a part answer.
That's a great example.
And I think that's
helpful now as people
are coming up with their ideas.
Because we're going
to be catering
to people in a for profit
track and a nonprofit track.
And I know that mission
statements are the underpinning
things of a nonprofit and
mission wonder or mission stray
can be a serious problem.
So the importance of
testing your idea up front
to make sure that you're
staying faithful to that,
there's a lot of back end work
that's going to need to happen.
I think that nonprofits don't
have the same level of agility
to be able to
switch necessarily.
So I think that's
an important thing
for any of my nonprofit
people out there to remember.
Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you for mentioning that.
I wasn't aware you
would have nonprofits.
And that's a great point.
Let's see, I have--
we work a lot through a
very iterative process.
There is a lot of mentoring.
We do a lot of pitch workshops
so that people start--
they start writing,
they start riffing,
and then they start getting more
cohesive their pitch scripts.
And the before and
afters tend to be really
powerful with the students.
So I'm wondering if you've got
an example of a venture that's
sort of like the what not to
wear that ended up turning
around and being successful.
Do you have like a
good before and after
of a team that might not
have had a clear value prop
in the beginning but was
able to pivot and succeed?
I have lots of examples.
I was thinking-- as
you're saying that,
I was thinking about--
the ones that come to
mind, for some reason,
are mostly medical.
Mostly because we've just
finished up our I-Corps cohort.
And this was a particular team.
They went in, they
had an adhesive,
a medical bandage adhesive that
their problem they were trying
to address was when you have
an open wound or a burn victim,
the actually redressing of
those wounds tears the part
of the healed skin off when
they're-- so it's very painful.
And they were trying
to address the pain
by developing an adhesive
onto this bandage that
would break down under light,
a certain type of UV light.
And they went to nurses
that were treating
patients on wound care
floors and the nurses said,
we don't care.
They said, aren't you
worried about the pain?
No, we don't care
about the pain.
This is 35 customer
interviews in.
They said, no, we don't care.
And it's like, what do you mean?
Well, of course we
care, generally.
But we have to pick one
of those two bandages
that are in the
cabinet over there.
We don't have any power
or influence ability.
So they completely had to
pivot out of that segment.
And moving from the
wound care nurses,
they went directly to the
head wound care nurse.
They said, well, how do
we get different bandages
into that cabinet?
And she said, I don't care.
And they're like, well, what
do you mean you don't care?
Well, of course I
care that there's pain
and that there should be
alternative solutions.
But we have to go
with the ones that
are approved cost-wise
that fit into that cabinet.
Now they are 65 interviews in,
and there have been demoralized
one step along the way.
And at the end, they
eventually they said, well,
who decides which ones
go into those cabinets?
And it was the reimbursement
officer upstairs.
And they ended up with the
reimbursement officers going--
and he's desperate for
anything, any solution that
could resolve pain.
He's willing to put a
more expensive bandage
into that cabinet if it's going
to reduce the pain scores,
because he's reimbursed,
the hospital system
is reimbursed off
of the pain scores.
See, they didn't know that.
They didn't understand that.
They thought the total solution
was just immediately addressing
the pain that the patient had.
But only through up
to 80 interviews now
before they realized they
have a bigger solution
than they ever could imagine.
And they actually had to
go back into the laboratory
and readdress the
adhesive, because he
wanted it to be a stronger
adhesive but breakdown quicker.
And they were already
re-engineering.
So that team went on
to start a company.
They raised several million
dollars, got their new product
issue.
They're an FDA
regulatory pathway now.
And they would have never known
if they had just simply built
the product and tried to sell
it to wound care clinics,
they would have never
figured that out.
I hope that's a little
bit of an example.
I'm just sort of
trying to get over
my personal squeamish
factor to see
the heart of the story,
which was fantastic.
Sorry about that.
No, not at all.
Yeah, there's several others.
The one I mentioned about there
was a heart, not a transplant
but a heart pacemaker.
They had come up with a
way of a permanent battery
getting power off the flow
of blood through the heart
and transitioning that
power back to the pacemaker.
And the problem is that's
an interesting idea,
because you hate
to get a pacemaker
and 20 years later
have to open up,
do another open-heart
surgery to get it repaired
or get the battery replaced.
But they found out the
people don't get pacemakers
until their late '70s.
And they don't live long enough
for the batteries to go down.
So there was no need for that.
However--
That is a solution
looking for a problem.
--the same technology became
a turbine to drive drones.
And so you could repower
the batteries in a drone.
They assess themselves.
Well, what other technologies
have battery issues?
And there were a number of them.
And that was the
one they focused on,
so a completely
different [INAUDIBLE]..
Wow.
So just a couple examples.
So you spoke a little
while ago about basically--
oh, you know what, I know
we're running out of time.
I had one final question.
No, I have two
questions actually.
Is that all right with you?
No, it's fine by me.
Sure, sure.
OK, firstly, we're talking
about how other partners--
it's not just direct partners.
It's just not consumers.
There are a lot
of people that are
integrated into the success.
You were saying it
took 80 interviews
to get to the guy upstairs
who really had the answer.
So do you know as far as those
partnerships are concerned,
that's really important.
But also, when you're
creating your own team,
partnerships are
incredibly important.
How does one go
about identifying
the right team and the right
partners that can contribute to
or are aligned with
the value problem?
Yeah, that's a
really good question.
You know, there is a
bit of a conundrum,
because a lot of
times the value prop
is delivered by the
underlying technology.
But the underlying
technology is designed,
developed, maintained, and
implemented by the team.
And so to a large
extent, the team
is fundamental to the
value proposition.
So if what you have now is
an idea but no solution,
you have an idea for
how you would solve
a particular problem, but
you don't have the solution,
you're in a pretty
good place in order
to identify through the
customer discovery activity
what is the unique
and compelling problem
and how does that manifest
in terms of their pain.
What does it limit the
customer from doing?
And what does, if
it was resolved,
what else could they be
doing more effectively?
And then that speaks very
vividly to the clear features
and attributes and
deliverables that you have
to have in that final product.
So if you're one member of what
needs to be a three member team
and you're doing this
assessment and you come up
with a clear
articulation of what
those compelling
attributes are, you
can then do a similar type of
activity in backward fashion
as to identify where are
the key strengths, what do
I need with respect to these--
I mentioned in the business,
those key activities
and key resources.
Sometimes you need a
key database in order
to drive a pricing model.
Or you need someone to
build something like that.
And if you can
articulate that based
on what you heard directly
from the customer in terms
of the clear, compelling
features and attributes
they would need in order
to deliver that key value,
you can articulate
what the skill
sets are that are going to be
necessary in the ultimate team.
If you're not a team
already going in,
or better yet, even
if you are, if you're
open to part of the learning,
part of the discovery being
that the team has a
gaping weakness in terms
of its ability to
deliver the value,
you ought to be
honest with yourself,
and say we've got to cap
that, we've got to fix it.
And again, if
you're clear enough
in what the customer
needs, I think
you'll be clear enough in
understanding and isolating
those skill sets.
And from there, it just becomes
a networking and marketing
and recruiting type
of activity that I
think is we're all
pretty familiar with.
Excellent.
It's not an easy thing though.
I'm usually dealing with
teams who are fixed going in.
And when they realize
there's a gap,
they look for an
external partner.
And they're never open, as
maybe many of your teams
will be, open to reshaping
the fundamental team itself.
That's a great concept.
I think that's an
important takeaway too.
We've got a lot of students
who might have a great idea who
don't know who their
teammates need to be,
or we might have groups that are
looking for that other person.
So we're trying to facilitate
the kind of networking that
will enable people to
have awareness of this,
have the self-awareness
to be able to seek
the right teammates and
for people in the community
to have awareness
of this opportunity,
so that people can
find those natural fits
and those critical partners.
Yeah, and sometimes it
takes an intermediary
like you to facilitate that.
That's challenging.
Even if I am open
to hearing that I
need help finding that
specific person or persons,
that can be challenging.
So yeah, we don't have
that at Ohio State.
So I may call on you.
Absolutely.
We see a hundred ideas a year.
Actually, it's worth mentioning
that the competition has
primarily been in-person.
We pivoted sort of
as gracefully as we
could in the spring
for obvious reasons.
We're doing the entire
program virtually this year.
Most of the MIT
students are off campus.
It's a year-ish long program.
So we want to make it fair
and equitable for everybody.
So to that end, students
anywhere can be part of teams.
Teams just have to
have one MIT student.
So if you have any students who
might be interested in this,
we certainly can try
to broker something
to get this on the map.
Because at least we're
Zoom is concerned,
there's like the sky's
the limit on these teams
and partnerships.
And what's the deadline for when
the team has to be finalized?
That's a great question.
The applications are due
the first week of February.
But I think that as the
projects and programs sort of go
through various
iterations, I think
we should have a great idea
of what teams are roughly
by the first week of February.
But there could
still be a little bit
through one-on-one
mentorships, students
might figure out that we really
need another person here.
So in order to
maximize success, we
are probably open to the idea
of adding people as needed.
OK, great.
No, I definitely would
have people interested.
So if you could--
Perfect.
--stay connected, let me know.
Let's do that.
Theo, did you have one final
question before we wrap up?
Yeah, absolutely.
So Dr. Camp, I think
you started to reference
this in your spoilers.
But I think if you have any--
if you could share one
kind of pearl of wisdom
or one key takeaway for our
teams in this competition,
I think that would be really
helpful for the teams here
and those watching
asynchronously.
Yeah, no, thanks.
That's a great way to wrap up.
You know, in
thinking about that,
there's so many pieces
that go together.
And I don't know if you
guys put more weight
on the final presentation in
terms of determining winners
or not, or if it's just
kind of a cumulative effect
as teams move
through the program,
but the ability to tell
an effective story--
and when I, again, heard
that it's about a five minute
presentation with the
five minutes of Q&A,
I want to emphasize
that if the team's not
able to tell the story in a
compelling convincing fashion
in the five minutes,
they'd better
be able to answer the questions
in a compelling and convincing
way.
Because they're going
to get the key questions
that the reviewers, judges,
whatever they're called
are going to be listening for.
However, my advice would be by
getting familiar and testing
very clearly and
honestly, openly
questioning and challenging
your own understanding
and underlying
assumptions, you're
going to have a much
more compelling way
to tell the key considerations,
whether it be market that
differentiates your opportunity
or it's the compelling solution
or whether it be just kind of
economic or social or human
impact you're able
to have, you need
to isolate and be
able to articulate
what that really moving
moment that moving element is.
It's not enough to just
dotting I's and crossing T's.
There's probably so many good
ideas in this competition.
The team that can
get that idea across
in a believable realistic way--
and the best believability is
that if you've either done it,
or if you haven't done it,
you have connected directly
with those end
users and partners,
so that they'll
tell you-- those who
have done it can tell
you that this is doable,
this is believable.
In other words, it's making
it real, as real as possible.
And the moment you have to
say, I think, I believe,
you realize that's
a compelling gap.
That's an area of challenge
that you're going to have.
Making it real,
making it concise,
hitting the critical
elements that
make your opportunity
differentiated
from the others--
and because now
you've done that,
you'll have so much
more confidence in terms
of how you tell that story.
It doesn't sound like one thing.
That was the best
possible answer.
Now anybody who is here
for our kickoff conference
and keynotes and
anybody who's watching
who will watch this who saw
that first event, it all
comes down to storytelling.
There are so many
entrepreneurship innovation
initiatives at the
Institute, and everybody has
their own sort of value added.
And apart from
being arts-driven,
the thing that people come
here and the big takeaway
is storytelling.
It's sort of the underpinning
of the entire operation.
So I promise we didn't
feed Dr. Camp that answer.
It just it's so perfectly
within the theme
of being successful with
helping to launch your venture.
So that couldn't
have been better.
[LAUGHS]
And with the
cathedral background,
I've got to say, Amen.
Exactly.
Hey, if I can be
at the final event,
I'd love to see some of
those great stories that
are going to get told.
Oh, absolutely.
We will definitely be in touch.
Just as a guest.
That would be fantastic.
So if any of the three of you
stalwart soldiers here have
any questions, let me know.
We can also forward
things on to Dr. Camp.
So if that is it for
everybody, then I'm
just going to thank
Dr. Camp for his time.
It was fantastic
having you here.
We really appreciate this.
And it was so engaging,
especially even
for Zoom, you know?
It was it was wonderful.
We can't thank you enough.
Well, glad to be with you.
Thanks, again.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.